welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division episode three was
literally
one word away from blowing the secrets
of west view wide open
wanda vision seriously just pulled a
magnitude on us
pop what what is he trying to say pop
what magnitude spoiler warning for one
division episode three
as wanda delivers her twin sons billy
and tommy future young avengers wiccan
and speed vision interrogates his shifty
neighbors
agnes and herb about geraldine aka sword
agent monica
rambo she came here because we're all
she came in because we're all what what
are you trying to tell me
she came here because we're all stop it
because we're all what magnitude what is
he trying to say herb's
next word would have confirmed a lot
about what westview is exactly
the whole sitcom pocket reality's
purpose function relationship with wanda
vision
sword and agnes even how the hell vision
is alive once again
i am gonna break down what that next
word probably was and because we love
hexagons here the
six options for herb's big secret and
why it's important that he knows it
okay likeliest answer because we're all
trapped the end of this episode reveals
the sword perimeter around westview a
military camp floodlights and some
structures in the town visible from the
outside
this confirms to us that westview was a
pre-existing establishment before
wanda and her sitcom reality warping
phenomenon began
and the fact that the town welcome sign
is visible on the outside
tells us that westview is both what this
place is called inside the bubble and in
the real world
it's 732 area code and mentions of
hackensack tell us that westview is
in new jersey so all of wanda's
neighbors herb jones dr nielsen the rest
could just be people who lived in that
town right up until wanda's reality
warping
accidentally enveloped and trapped them
the westview residents tend to play
along with the sitcom scenarios but
they've been increasingly glitching
showing flashes of cognition
mrs hart broke down stop it
stop stop it stop it
which might be why agnes says the same
thing here
stop it and yeah everyone has similar
moments including now in this episode
when herb cuts
into the wall and dr nielsen says he can
never escape
which leads directly into herb's big
mystery line here
and if he was going to say trapped that
would answer the question of why that
sword agent has come to west view
to liberate all of these trapped
bystanders
from wanda's fantasy but herd might have
intended to be even more specific than
that because we're all
under wanda's spell this would explain
why agnes reacted the way she did
she doesn't want vision and wanted to
know that wanda has god level powers
over this world and at any point could
go
there's a reality stone on them however
this would require herb to
know what juan is doing all of them
while he is in a bit of a cahoots with
agnes i don't think herb as a victim of
all this
would have a firm enough grasp of
wanda's sorcery to understand what's
exactly happening
unless he is acting because we're all
agents of sword another explanation for
being able to see a structure from the
outside is that westview could be
the kind of ursats potemkin village fake
town
like seahaven in the truman show or
those atomic village test sites or
something like the old shield fake
hospital that fury kept cap in at the
end of captain america first avenger
a new jersey town would not be that far
from camp lehigh
the shield base visited in the first cap
movie winter soldier and in-game
if shield did transition into sword they
would have
a nearby command center sword could have
set up all of this to contain wanda
and all of these neighbors could be
theatrically trained
fakers like the supporting cast of the
truman show that could have been the
deeper significance of vision's
shakespeare quote all the world's a
stage all the men and women merely
players now the problem with this
explanation
why would herb throw a fellow sword
agent monica rambo
under the bus like that maybe monica's
been going rogue going off script or
maybe some sword agents are in too deep
and begin to turn on each other so
yeah i'm not too sure about that one but
also another option just to get this one
out of the way
but before i continue thanks to our
friends at bang energy for sponsoring
this video
bang every can of bang energy has zero
calories zero carbs zero sugar
zero artificial colors each 16 ounce can
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
super creo teen coq10 and bcaas
i am sipping on black cherry vanilla
it's like i have now found the only soda
flavor i want for the rest of my life i
drink a bang when i need to pick me up
in the morning or when i just need to
plow through a long video and i want my
mind to be alert which i know you guys
need it to be
check out bang on instagram get 25 off
your order at bang energy.com when you
use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy a variety pack of bang
energy or a whole pack of just your
favorite flavor
editor john loves radical skedaddle and
off-screen producer zach drinks their
sweet tea
flavor whereas i am team black cherry
vanilla thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25
off your order at bang energy.com using
the code newrockstars25
i don't think her boy is going to say
because we're all hallucinations or
in wanda's head that would not answer
the question of why monica arrived
also again the town exists in the real
world people
and if these were like perfect delusions
in wanda's mind they probably would not
glitch into point of view separate from
that of wanda so if we
assume the west view residents are
separate from sword it begs the question
what other antagonistic forces is sword
now trying to disrupt
by sending monica in there because we're
all
witches or demons yeah an answer like
this would explain why
agnes is so desperate to keep vision
from knowing the truth as a witch
she would not want vision to know
exactly what she
and her demonic allies are doing to them
going by the comics using the illusion
of her kids actually pieces of mephisto
soul to trick wanda while draining her
over chaos magic
this would be similar to the big season
1 reveal of the good place spoiler
warning
it's actually an experimental version of
the bad place and the neighbors are
demons in disguise trying to torture you
but while we are in this line of
thinking the actual answer might have
already been given to us
because we're all dead or in hell
back in the first trailer agnes asked
vision
am i dead no why would you think that
because you are
that is the one thing we know about
vision he's dead
however he is alive here must be the
same
how all these other residents exist so
if he's dead
they might be dead too west view could
rest atop
a hell mouth and wanda's bubble is a
kind of transitory
plug in that hole kind of like a cloth
stuffed into a leak that
gradually soaks in soaks and dribbles a
bit but
everyone in westview who's not a sword
agent the people who think they belong
there
like vision are really souls that can
only exist
in this transitory plane it might all
exist because vision
because as a synthesis he might have
complicated rules over where his soul is
supposed to go
or whether or not he really has one and
now wanda could be trying to wrestle him
back into reality
by making some kids with him so that he
doesn't get deported to hell let me know
which of these six directions
you think herb was going i am wearing
our new latest obsession shirt and
unusual couple available at our merch
store newrockstarsmerch.com it's got
secret easter eggs that you can find
only by using augmented reality these
are selling out fast
be sure to get your hands on one so that
you can write in a custom shout out for
our episodes of inside marvel follow me
at ea boss follow new rockstar subscribe
to rockstars here on youtube hit that
notification bell thank you for watching
and rip magnitude you pulled us steve
rogers which makes you worthy forever in
our hearts
pop i can't even say it
[Music]
you